and he was always the man words of
wisdom we got to do this
and uh my last his last living brother
who is now just in the beginning of uh
stages of dementia used to come down my
house and sit there and say
your dad he says he wasn't mike he says
he wasn't my brother he was my father
wow
he says he was everything to us
hello everyone hola mis amigos
you're listening to oh my god hi
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg hi
all right so
support the oh my god high podcast
broadcast
support the oh my god hi podcast is
brought to you by our friends
and our level partners at manscape the
leaders in male grooming also
if you're going to hit your uh nuts hit
your cooler and the prosimium right
there
the prosimium perennium the taint
join the two million men worldwide
why are you living in there there's four
million levels there
join the two million men worldwide who
trust manscape
for their shower time routine by going
to manscape.com for 20 off of free
shipping with the code omghi the fourth
generation performance package
absolutely changed the grooming game
along with the refined body wash
to roll out
for your hygiene routine listen
this is how great manscape is you know i
watch tv and smell my own levels and
i would say that
they're less fragrant
because of manscape
and i'm not shocked into like what the
[ __ ] have i been doing
you can sit in traffic get home check
yourself out while you're looking at
your emails and and and not
either have to get up or find a warm
towel
[Music]
i i've never said this before
we had a dog that was named mimi
my grandmother liked
poodles
and when mimi got old
and these are the people that
raised me
now this this is a [ __ ] up thing
because that dog was with us for like 12
years
and instead of taking that dog to the
bed like some
a normal [ __ ] human being would do
she let me out
and she's in kind of like this
cul-de-sac and she called the animal
regulation
so the animal regulation came and my
grandmother said that's a dog right
there never seen that was my dog
and the dog got her around the neck and
she fought so i'm on my balcony i'm on
the front porch and i see that and that
that's been my dog for like 12 years
and when she walks back i said what the
what is this
she was sick
that he had grano he had like worms and
stuff was sick
probably nothing that a vet couldn't
have taken care of but instead of that
my grandmother let her loose
and they came
and they put that long thing on and i
mean i mean imagine man that that dog
was your in your family for 12 years
and deeply traumatic to watch and the
female head of the household
calls the animal regulation just takes
her away like a stray dog
that's [ __ ] up there's a dog in the
room as we record this that's
still over there you did the time i'm
gonna tell you what i did my grandma had
dementia i [ __ ] took any id off her
[ __ ] earrings and i put her in the
same place that mimi was
and i called the [ __ ] alzheimer
[ __ ] regulation hotline
and they came and got her they put the
long stick because they run
the [ __ ] lawn
and she fought
and i stood on the same porch
and i had to say nothing because she was
you know that dementia she wouldn't hurt
me anyway and they struggled to put her
in there and whatever [ __ ] chunk
glass fell off that's the only thing i
have from her that
[Laughter]
oh my god
it's got a worm so
it didn't go that bad you know
let me say this too let me say this
because i never talked about my family
my grandmother was not not the nicest
lady but never abandoned me until they
say hey talk to her you know maybe you
know talk to her and she'll she was
already getting ready to go
and uh
her i think my mom was her oldest child
and there was three and three
and
what happened
no
you okay [ __ ] going on over there
that's uh that's hudson the word animal
controls dude he's just licking himself
to the point where he's now coughing on
hairballs well when he comes let us know
if we can [ __ ] throw that
[Laughter]
so so let me say this
my grandmother was you know
a tough lady
she had six biological children
and when she was losing her mind not one
of those [ __ ] had to say
allegedly stood up
and said that's my mother i'll take care
of her
this and that and not only that
every one of them went to her house
while she was still alive and [ __ ]
stole from her
wow
stole from her that's not good and my
grandmother had this one this one chain
that she had forever it was her mom's
and so one thing that i want i mean i
lived in that house i was the person
that took the most care of her
she said george you wanted while she was
still alive i said no grandma i don't
want it i'm going to take it from you
i'll leave it to you
and one of those [ __ ] took it
and i spent
almost a million dollars
so that my grandma wouldn't stay in a
nursing home and never did one of those
[ __ ] relatives say alleged
ever do anything for her their own
mother
didn't never brought her groceries never
came over to say hello never did
anything from that front then take from
her
and i mean that's where i come from
that's a family that i come out with
that wasn't my wife's family at all
nobody took anything from her they did
come and visit you know and and so it
was always at my house but
they did and and you got to have
somebody tolerant my father who
still the wisest man i've ever known
when my grandfather my my mom's dad he
was put in a uh
he used to call them resting homes right
there about my house and pico what was
actually called what were they these
call them
they were rested i mean listen
they weren't called rehab centers and
you think you think there's political
crest correctness now a
arresting home yeah [ __ ] i don't play
it's where you put [ __ ] yeah
they're old out to pasture yeah they
should have called a
pasture palace my grandfather was old my
grandfather is an old vista
he's a tough old guy and he went in
there and he wanted a television for his
room so my dad went and bought him a
television they were black and whites
back then colors were just coming out
bottom of black and white part of the
keyboard
before
tv
get it out of my room
he didn't want a black and white tv he
wanted a color tv
so my dad went out and bought him a
color tv to put in his room keep the old
man happy that's his wife's father
next thing you know my father my
grandfather is hitting my dad up hey can
you loan me 50 bucks
and he said yeah but what do you want
fifty dollars for hey you don't ask me
what i want the money for you they're
gonna give it to me or not it's awesome
and so my dad said here he wanted the
money because he didn't like the food
they were serving it was all american
all anglo food there he wanted to be
what a lockdown facility
he wanted to go and buy mexican food for
himself
so everything my my grandfather was
chingando about my dad just met his
needs
just so it'd be easy on that on his own
so
he went out to go get it or he wants
somebody to go get no he went out on his
own he could walk right there within a
block and grab some food and bring it
back
he just uh okay so
i'm on the influence of that thing
but that's not bad
no
what i want to say in this podcast is
you know i always thought of myself as a
young guy you started going on the road
and i'm having some
i've been saying i'm having issues
performing but i'm 60 years old man and
it's tough to [ __ ] fly around when
you're 60. like yesterday when i went to
the raider game and we flew in from uh
pueblo and
reuben lance's bag
to go spend four hours in a [ __ ] i
would have done it but i'm actually was
happier in the hotel room
because i'm 60 man sure that's a lot of
then i went to vancouver and then i was
i went to [ __ ] did america's got
talent i mean
you know as age comes you get tired yes
i know and and um
[ __ ] i'm 10 years older than you but but
nobody thinks you know he's gonna send a
message like that like i was i
i could have got out of that uh
and said hey i'll go down and throw my
name around i said [ __ ] it man i'm just
gonna go back to the hotel
but
in our culture people wait
until it's too late before you decide to
have a [ __ ] good time or travel or do
share with your kids
or or or do sit with your wife you know
one of those the most amazing one the
saddest [ __ ] things i ever saw was i
have a house in the kingdom i go play
golf and on christmas morning
i was ahead of a guy and him and no they
were ahead of me
and the wife
they look like they've been married a
long time
and the wife got flowers and she put him
on the conveyor belt and the guy
said what do you want what do you want
those for they're only going to die
and he put them back
and i thought we're all going to die but
if your old lady wants some flowers on
christmas [ __ ] buy her some flowers
[ __ ] why would you be like oh
these are
because they're gonna die
you're gonna put them back not that's
[ __ ] up man yeah so no no no you've
been married a long time i i was married
i probably won't ever see be married
again but you know you have your old
lady man you have your wife you guys are
like that that's an honorable thing man
and then you see a lot of guys like me
that come up with a family like that
and how are you supposed to be somebody
that you're close to when
you're almost like a [ __ ] uh uh
fencer keeping those people away
from their mom and they don't want to
see her anyways i mean that's [ __ ] up
man yeah yeah you know when when she was
alive and i even asked her i said hey
what do you want me to do when you know
time comes when you're
when you're not here
and she's like oh you know i don't think
i want a funeral george because i'm here
by myself and nobody comes to visit me
you come to visit me and then when i'm
dead and and you tell me if this is
wrong when she goes oh my mom i miss her
so much i love her they're all there
crying for her when she was alive nobody
saw her yeah so my grandmother said
[ __ ] no just no funeral man like
that's it really here i am and nobody
comes and sees me and then when i'm gone
and that's another cultural thing that
happens to us is that when somebody's
[ __ ] alive they're not even that far
away and then nobody goes over there and
nobody goes and sees her and then if you
say hey why don't you go see your mom
man and and you don't
and then she's gone and all that i mean
this this is a culture of like
it's like
me too the [ __ ] latino culture is the
[ __ ] me first
[ __ ] culture man i remember when uh
my son was born
you know before he was born my i had two
daughters
and my dad who had six daughters and and
myself
so my dad comes up to me says son he
says i know you want a boy
he said but if it's another girl he says
count your blessings
he says because i'll tell you right now
girls come back and take care of their
fathers
boys
become adults get married and raise a
family of their own and they have their
own responsibilities but girls will
always come back
to take care of their dads he said so
when you
when that baby's born he says if it's
another girl count your blessings if
it's a boy
i'll pay for the mariachis at the
baptism
so we got our boy he paid for the
mariachi yeah man but it is it is uh
you don't like your dad with the whole
uh i'm proud of you stuff like
is is it because what did his dad do do
you remember your
dad his dad his dad his first well his
real dad died young
and his stepdad got run out of dodge
because his stepdad tried to booger his
sister
you know he he tried molesting his my
dad's sister and so he got run out of
dodge by by everybody in the village
and so he didn't know my dad was a dad
to about 10 or 11 siblings
he was he was the man
the guy that was your father was your
father right yes oh he told me his
father yeah yes
and did anything
did he he didn't inherit any of those
bad traits from his own no because no
my dad was a good and honorable man like
he knew like he knew he was like that
that [ __ ] i don't wanna know that
[ __ ] no he took care of him he took
care of he took care of his mother
he made sure all of his brothers were in
line when his mother passed away
i remember everybody was down my house
because his mom had now moved from new
mexico out to she was living in carson
with one of her daughters
and his brothers came out here and
they're all in my house i remember my
dad saying author he says
mom wants everybody to live on you know
we've got lives ahead of us you've got
to keep continue to go on it's sad right
now but we're going to continue and he
was always the man words of wisdom we
got to do this
and my last his last living brother who
is now just in the beginning of uh
stages of dementia used to come down my
house and sit there and say
your dad he says he was a might he says
he wasn't my brother he was my father
wow
he says he was everything to us
and so
my mom who was 10 years younger than my
dad was raised as neighbors
and my mom actually married my dad got
on just because she wanted to get away
from her mom and dad yeah and this is
why a lot of people got married she was
friends with my dad's brothers
and they'd be down the house my dad
would leave for work in the morning say
hey
we would chop for the
for the house
have it done get it done today okay and
he'd leave and it'd be my mom and look
at the time and she'd say hey you guys
better get out there and cut the grass
cut the cut the wood up chop the wood
for before he gets home you know he's
gonna be upset and my uncle dan would
sit there saying who cares hey it's my
brother he ain't my dad i'm tired of
doing what he told me to do my dad had
come from where he says hey what
happened to the wood he says i'm just
getting ready to go out chop it right
now and he just because he was afraid of
my dad but my dad did everything for him
my sister ran away i had an older sister
run away from the house she was at the
corner
just about four houses down from my
house and
another sister another older one but
younger than her
she goes out there she comes back she's
daddy daddy she says go get her she's
right there at the corner go bring her
back
my dad opened up his wallet took out
twenty dollars and said here take it to
her tell her it's all i can afford
tell if that's what she wants to do yeah
she did
oh wow why did she take out what did she
think at the house oh i have i have no
idea because i was i was young then
i mean i'm 71 now and she's got to be in
her 80s still alive yeah you talked to
her yeah
i just ever tell you why she took off no
i've never asked her and she was a she
was an ochola from
from the
from the bottom i think that'd be a good
question
because you know sometimes people man
they they just that's their thing man
like they don't want to stay
you know they don't want to stay where
they're at i will ask her now that you
said it but you know what when i grew up
over there in saffron mission hills like
all those [ __ ] dudes man they all
worked around there and general motors
was out there and they all wanted to
work at general motors and and you know
i never want to
i'm going to say those guys what their
lies ended up bad but i never wanted
what those guys wanted for their lives
like i just didn't feel like that was me
like whatever the [ __ ] i was gonna be
i wasn't gonna be these dudes like i
didn't wanna come from here i i didn't
mind coming from there i didn't want to
end up there i remember when i got out
of the army i wanted
i wanted to go to college
one of my dreams i said i want to go to
college and i want to play football
and so i went and i talked to the coach
and he said well come on what school was
that that was rio hondo college at the
time
and i said hey i'm i'm a tour i'm not
that kid that started playing football
for you a long time ago right i'm mature
i'm ready i'm ready to give everything
you want he said well come on out i told
my dad
looking for a job it's hard to find a
job
i said dad i just want to go to college
i want to play football my dad says
you're not going to become a
professional football player
he says you got to think about getting a
job
he finally told me he said were you good
fourth no i
no i wasn't you had pretty good signs
though yeah i had i had size and i had
desire and with the size and desire to
have i know i would have been good at
that time
so i went ahead
and my dad hits me up and he says hey
my my guys at work tell me that they're
hiring a ford motor company
which is right by my house
where was that tell me where that was
that's it uh rosemead and washington
okay between paramount and rosemead on
washington boulevard wow and so
i lived right off of paramount
between whittier and and washington so
it was close
so he says go apply if you don't get the
job
go play football
so i applied and they hired me
and that that was a whole change of life
because
had they not hired me i'd have started i
was already going to college but i had
to start playing football i wouldn't had
time for anything else when i had no
time for no marriages no nothing else
that turned out i didn't do that so then
i ended up getting married six months
later
okay i want to say this when i was doing
my first show
or maybe i shouldn't say
there was a guy that worked on our show
that pitched out of college and he was a
in a really good pitcher and he could
have gotten drafted okay and this is for
all the guys that are out there young
guys but maybe they're in junior high in
high school whatever
so
he he went to a college and he was a
really good pitcher he was going to get
drafted
he had a girlfriend in college and she
said to him
what's going to happen to us
if you get drafted you're going to go
away
and you know you know what
are you going to break up with me such
and such whatever okay and he's a pro he
was a prospect high level prospect
he she got him to stop playing baseball
and then a year later you know when she
found out that
that she was sleeping with the dude's
best friend
oh
okay
so
he threw a curvy
[ __ ] knuckleball
and shaved from one side for operation
so let me say to anybody that's not
girls too how if you're good at a sport
and somehow you know you you know
your parents take you to practice and
you're good and you're better than
everybody else
and then you go to
you know a camp or whatever and those
things are
you're isolated because if you want to
be good you're going to have to be
isolated you're going to put in time
you're not going to be good hanging out
you know whether the [ __ ] fbw
whatever it's called or whatever
[ __ ] stephen steakhouse the [ __ ]
mafia buying a fur coat over there in
the bar
like good fellows over there yeah yeah
but to be good
or to be great
or to have a career or to be someone
there's a lot of isolation that comes
with it there's a lot of pain that comes
with it
because
if you're a tennis player or if you're a
and you're out there by yourself the the
25 people that want to pull you away
from what what is your god-given talent
are never with you
but they affect you all of a sudden you
lose and you say [ __ ] i should have won
that thing
and then gradually you're less and less
and less but you know
the tennis players and all the the
people like the uh girl that
you know the media was [ __ ] ragging
on media
you know like her they make fun of her
mental illness
the media never attacked an athlete for
their mental health
ever
and it's and as crazy as it is over here
they say oh that you shouldn't do that
that person is mentally ill
the fact that our our during the
olympics
or doing whatever
that our own media
would tmz or whatever would make fun of
a young girl and her mental toughness
and her mental stability it's the way we
are people are willing to buy under that
message
yeah that's what sells and that's why
they watch they want to see yeah hey
you've been spoon fed you've been now
let's take her down it just ripped out
horrible and and it is and you know when
people when people say
and i'm not one to say that i was going
to be
an all-american and all pro i wouldn't
anything i just know that i'd have done
my best and once dedicated anything that
i set my mind to it's worked out in this
case
it didn't work out there so i set my
mind something else and then we ended up
going you know what i've only met you
may february january whatever but i
think that if you would have just if if
you would have wanted to be a a football
player you'd have gone to college i
think you you could have been a
professional football player
because you because you are right here
you remember every detail so play books
[ __ ] that you had it but also you're a
team player and you have respect and i
mean those are the people that go far
yeah you're a man of grit which can get
you the most things you want i i can
tell you i think that [ __ ] hit me more
than hit you dude oh no i'm oh no i'm
feeling good but i'm
you dropped convalescent home at one
point and i love that that was a strong
job
no listen i know everything i said it's
true family too and that's just that
hurts man
you know i i i say
that
i want to get two things clear
for all the viewers or listeners out
there number one
i did the right thing it was no burden
on me taking my mother-in-law and taking
care of my wife's family because my wife
is part of me i know that that so we're
all good and i'm glad that things worked
out the way they did well i don't mean
i'm glad she's dead but i mean
no no but she needed a place to go and
my wife just keeps telling me on a daily
basis why do you keep picking on my mom
over here
no not here everywhere
everywhere but no it it was all worth it
i'm not one bit sorry i did it i'd do it
all over again it was a pleasure i'm
glad we gave her a place to rest
you know and she had a peaceful ending
number two
the dedication you say
it takes
there's no doubt in my mind i put in
just as much time as anybody
at my work
in homicides right so
i know
going that extra but it meant
giving up other things wait a minute but
also you were the first one that said it
was one person and not multiple people
and that and and they made fun of you
and then that guy said hey when you
leave the room they [ __ ] you
yeah yeah and you were the person that
said that that's really what uh what the
forensics or these books or btk i talk
about circles that somebody has the idea
that that everybody disagrees with
and then it becomes that because they
can't think that
because it's built on data and then they
go like
and they're not they're not data they
they go but like instincts so they would
say you know this is this is more than
one person and you said this is one
person yeah
that's true so that's true there
everything worked out good what was the
other one did you have another no no
just myself
and the fact that i dedicated the time
okay so when people listen to this thing
you first of all you don't want your
wife to be mad at you no again because
if you're witnessing yeah
that's a constant okay but but you're
not mad i mean i don't know i only
remember this one she was
she was beautiful yeah she won't be
upset at this one at all no no
but but you know when she came and she
was walking towards me and you know i
saw like i felt like i already knew her
like we were family she's like i feel
like i already know she said the same
thing yeah she did really did that's so
sweet
but and you think you're familiar now i
leave i leave the house just say say hi
to george
i said you don't know that well just
create george hey but it's a big thing
how many shows have we done what what
what was your show here oh gills for
sure i think you were i can number 11.
okay so then uh we've done 20. and so i
i think i've done about i think we've
done about 12 13 together
okay i'm going to say this i don't know
this okay so brian brian was here at the
beginning how many did brian do uh so it
would have been
brian was on yours would have been 11.
he was on the first one yeah okay so
brian was never really good at at this
but you know i met brian like you know
20 years ago in sacramento and i took
him on the road with me and brian was a
guy that
even in the beginning when when my show
was about to come out the first one
brian was the guy that would say like
hey i saw you went on on vh1 i did like
the bh-1 top 20 songs and i was i was
everywhere i was on this i did that and
he was the only one that called me so he
and i stayed together
a long time the way that he left the
show
that was made third
i mean
i'll say a man doesn't do that to
another man especially a guy he's known
for 20 years who took him on the road
for 16.
it was unsettled and it's not cool man
like i never called him and said hey he
he saw me outside and i said hey are you
all right and yeah i'm okay and then the
next day he called me at 10 o'clock in
the morning he said can i talk to you
and did it over the phone that's not
man-to-man that's not you that's not me
that's how you aaron i don't know how
you talk to your vet but whatever
but you know what man i'm a good dude i
paid that guy more than he got paid more
than that 90 of the guys get paid and
that's how he goes out and i just
thought
so you you being here this year is is a
thing for me because because this
wouldn't it still wouldn't be it
wouldn't be on my voice well trust me
it's it's
it's been it's more fun for me this i i
tell everybody and everybody that knows
me knows
hey you know remember we used to play
ball and get out on that ball field for
two hours a night all the troubles go
away yeah it's all here we just have fun
and i love that guy but he's not you man
so i'm just i'm grateful but i
appreciate a man that says to another
man hey this is why i did this this way
this is it you know you didn't have to
say i hope you understand but there's
something there's something to that man
like there's something to
a a man being a man i remember going up
to your house
uh the first
uh
i think it was the only time the time i
went to your house
and then you come to my house yeah momo
was there
and you came out and i said hey my wife
said i better tell you about this and
that's when i showed you the picture
i want to be late and i started telling
them that i had little
i had a little incident in the house he
said wait a minute wait a minute are you
trying to tell me you don't want to do
this anymore
and i said no no no no that's that's not
it at all i enjoy this this is fun for
me and he says
okay wait
no no pearl doesn't want you doing it
with me anymore no
no no and then now this is like built-in
calendar work but you know what but
that's what i'm used to i'm used to
people telling me
you know
no no not at all are we done no we got
as much time as you [ __ ] come in
you said people had to come in here
no uh there's a podcast before it's
doing their 500th episode that's what it
was what was that uh it's the dollop
with uh
dave ryan and gareth anthony
nope that's the edible talking i did not
say their names right
have you smelled manscape refined body
wash fellas the ladies love their
signature scent you and your boys will
be
oh so fresh and so clean when you start
off your self-care routine with the
ultimate body wash you know i'm not
going to say what age the body wash is
good for all ages of webbles because as
you get older
and you've been married a long time
and you know that meat can get gamier
than elk
[Music]
let's thank manscape for keeping it real
in the field
go ahead
okay
my mother testimonial
all right keep keep it's not just for
deer season anymore
keep the grooming game going along with
the performance package 4-0
inside the package you'll find their
lawnmower 4-0 trimmer weed whacker ear
and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver toner
performance boxer briefs and a travel
bag to hold your goodies
i think if you're a soccer player or
love the game of soccer
i i think that's probably the game where
the whales get the most irritation
friction probably yeah
you know we have the ghetto rosau you
know he's a grown man you were destined
if you're using death index as a grown
man
then you're down
you know the kind of your pubes look
like the back of an old tv like you take
off the back it's all white
get right
get this
get 20 off free shipping with the oh my
god hi at manscape.com gail cabron
that's 20 off and free shipping with the
code omghi that's oh my god hi at
manscape.com let's do this one together
like you're doing all the other
commercials ready keep your balls
trimmed fresh fresh and clean with
landscape
your werewolves will thank you if they
could talk
well just don't listen it'll prevent
your sack from touching the water
when you're using the toilet
i kind of like that
wait till you flush and then your
[ __ ] nuts are halfway to handsome
damn down there
okay so what i would say to people okay
i went to the radio game yesterday
i flew in from pueblo
uh
they expected me to do things i love the
raiders i was just they expected i would
have done these things
but they were sent to me without
uh
an email
oh a gate
credentials
so you know as much as i love the
raiders you know because the rams uh
it's my first bad experience with a
professional team man
oh
so i'm going to say that i just want to
say that because
by the time this is it i hope it's
resolved so when this is on i'll go back
and i'll say
you know it's resolved but also that
there's a
urgency in one person that doesn't mean
it's an urgency to me or you exactly
yeah so when somebody knows how to do
their job you you're never supposed to
see that person
out of their mind
how's that supposed to make you feel
when i run up to
your hair
you know it's like all this [ __ ] is
supposed to be it has to be done the
proper way
so
this the chain of events that happened
uh yesterday at the raider stadium i'm
gonna tell you we'll put in here
i don't know the the details of it
but they treated me like i was less than
what they
less than what i am
to me i know who i am
but they didn't respect me for who i was
and that's why when the car was outside
and reuben got out and i could have got
out i said [ __ ] him i'm going back to
the hotel
there you go there you go
you forgot your wallet and your hey i
did but i
if i may quote a friend of mine
for they could learn so that was that
[ __ ] work you know what that was
there was a 7-eleven across the street i
went in there i thought i'd do a bunch
of these beef jerky
[Laughter]
there's 20 in there i go here's 50
dollars give me all of them i went to
the bathroom i wiped all that
and i didn't give him hey and i saw
people that had miami i gave them to
only the [ __ ] raiders eh because i
could eat some cooler yesterday
no no
uh do you guys want to do voicemails or
calls
oh by the way i did a little research i
thought we ordered a [ __ ] pizza what
happened
what
picture uh i did a little research there
was actually two women who uh
who tried to assassinate gerald ford he
was president
are you guys one of them was one of the
manson family girls yeah yeah speaking
from yeah yeah and the other one was uh
sarah something
uh but either way they both have been
out of jail for almost a decade now so
i guess it's just coming up on their
time like they both did 32 years 34
years
so
maybe hinckley's just coming up on
it's been long enough i don't know
okay
um good backstory in the essence of love
hey
let's talk about
i think all this stuff is great this is
mine but i also want you to talk about
this guy too so tim okay
so start where you want to start
okay uh david rocha who is now oh no not
with that boy it's the [ __ ] wreaker
voice you're not reading all right well
i'm just telling you this guy david
can you play one of the commercials that
that gill did
uh
right now so we can hear it in here i
can try and grab one give me a second
yeah
because i'm gonna tell the difference
between me and him that's why we're
[ __ ] wham broke up because i'm about
to get singing the other [ __ ]
it's a good thing i wasn't a fan of
wham
this uh can i say this bottle he did
eight years federal federal uh prison
what was his name david rocha he's a
pastor of his own little one he wrote
your own little church
where'd you meet him up uh through a
friend he contacted me reached out to me
he heard the podcast and uh no he had
never heard the podcast but he had heard
somebody else do a podcast that i did a
podcast with a long time ago
and he said this guy wants a wants to
talk to you and when he first reached
out to me because he was a pastor i said
i didn't want to do it because i don't
want to talk religion you know uh on a
podcast i i said
i said i'm going to talk to you so he
called we talked on the phone i said
here's here's the problem pastor
i said you represent
all things good and godly i said and i'm
not a hypocrite so i can't go
with my friends and on the george lopez
podcast and talk [ __ ] and drop the
f-bomb and do whatever i want to do
and then talk to you about god
i said it's like a conflict of interest
and i'm not hypocritical if you can do
this thing and leave god out of it
fine it doesn't mean that i don't
believe in god doesn't i just don't want
to talk religion
personally
what do you think religion uh speaking
well first of all there was two things
that people never talked about
um
anywhere near the holidays or a holiday
or whatever nobody ever talked religion
ever right yeah nobody would ask you who
you voted for because it was it wasn't
your problem
religion religion or politics nobody
would ask hey would you vote for it it
wasn't their business
and then now religion is spoken
everywhere dude yeah everywhere i i just
think religion is very personal and i
didn't feel like talking about exposing
myself
because just like politics half the
people are going to love you have people
are going to hate you but you know what
i think it was i think
that's your attitude right there i think
it was like that back then and people
and people didn't talk they didn't talk
about it and that should be the same
thing today it's just somebody has to
[ __ ] be right and somebody has to be
wrong
that's the only reason people talk
religion because somebody wants to say
well you didn't hear about this and you
didn't hear about that
that all could have gone on back then
and everybody had beautiful christmases
and thanksgivings where people weren't
fighting and shooting each other my mom
asked me at one time my dad had been
dead for several years and she says
amigo
you know this this voting thing right
here i have to ask you a question about
that i said mom you don't want to talk
to me
i said you may want to talk to one of my
sisters
and i said because mom when i got out of
the army i was a registered democrat
i said but
i've changed i'm a republican
and so
i know
what you're asking you know is going to
be
i said so maybe you ought to talk to one
of my sisters he says yes okay
she said what do you think your father
was my father was a laborer all his life
right i said what do you think your
father was and and i said mom i don't
know what she says he was a republican
he said if he had to pay for all of the
stuff he wasn't going to pay for other
people to get free stuff and yeah i
still he was a registered republican but
we never spoke
politics in my house it was a
difference between him and i and and we
never did it it hasn't affected my
family i don't know who's republican
even in my own kids
oh
even if somebody were to say something
hey we don't talk politicians at the
table
yeah so in in same way we talk religion
at the table same way with uh religion
and i didn't feel like
being a hypocrite you know saying oh
this is all good you know because i
didn't know what he was and he said no
we won't even mention that this is all
about just life and
because he's got a bunch of
uh let's say let's call them youth
at risk at-risk youth
that follow him can you say bhagavan is
or what you know they're they're they're
guys that are right on the borderline
and getting in trouble you know in and
out they know which way to go or they're
in trouble and he says let me ask you a
question yes if somebody's out there
right now and there's a thousand things
to do now you could become a social
media person and all that sure you could
you know
have a website
what what makes a kid a at-risk youth at
like 16 men what's in them but where
they come from something somebody that
doesn't have the support and is lacking
in love and doesn't know
you know are the guys on the streets
going to give me more love than i'm
getting over here on this side and what
he needs to learn is there are people
that love him that don't even know him
and are willing to help him out and so
that's what that's what they need in
order that's why they're at risk they're
at risk of going
that way
or staying on this side but you're at
risk on losing them and that's what i
hope that i can reach out to somebody
and it makes me feel wonderful to know
that i've impacted somebody that was
able to make it to this side as opposed
to the opposite that dude told you yeah
hey man you better get
and so he talked me into going on he
spent eight years in federal
penitentiary he was a bad dude
uh there's a picture of him on the back
he was a gangster he was a drug dealer
it's been eight years
uh in federal pen did time come out
and now he's okay check this out
i'm gonna read this book
usually books on tape right now
but i want to see with this dude
because um
somebody will write a book that's
a non-latino
like let's find a book look go look at
the thing
um
that uh hey margaret it's me it's
whatever that [ __ ] is that it's mean
yeah whatever the [ __ ] that somebody
writes a book not margaret chose but
whatever the book she referenced was yes
that that
a woman writes a book
wash your face girl or something
[ __ ] right is that what we call wash
your face
i don't know i'll keep looking we'll see
i think i think i'm better on weed
though
i was a little fiery today
yeah judy bloom is the author of the
fiery huh you were yeah and i was smart
judy bloom okay
so let's say about the right hair man
you know
judy bloom in her audience but also this
guy david rocha
has a story to tell
uh the new york times is not going to
look at this the l.a chinese is not
going to look at this
uh
so the fact that this guy would write
his story
knowing that it's not going to be on the
it may not ever be on the new york times
bestseller yes
but
and who who's even going to see it like
where is he going to see it hand it out
at uh the victory mission where the
memphis i have no idea i don't know the
victory mission
hey
we had a party one time and those guys
are like you know once they get out
they're anti-alcohol they're anti-weed
so every time that uh we would smoke
weed he'd be like
good job
you're enabling the devil to enter your
body
they always have some crazy uh yes uh
slogan so there is a book oh yeah girl
wash your face was that the book you
were thinking of i'd never heard of that
yeah [ __ ] that's what i said
didn't i say girl wash your face no you
said well i was like wash your face
girl all right well
i looked it up for the people who want
to take your recommendation i'm not done
with my recommendation okay so
what i saying the dunes morning yeah
the devil's entering your little devil
the devil
you're inhaling the devil's lungs
whatever the [ __ ] and then everybody
would be drinking and you know nobody
would listen to that dude the whole
night you know and then he would walk up
going hey but you got another one of
those yeah
just throw it out the window because you
know so
but all those books that people read
that become like
uh tv shows even with some [ __ ]
all about
you know i've been in television a long
time
i'm going to read this guy's book
page by page you know i'm dyslexic i'm
going to take my long time and i'm i'm
going to give you a book report on this
uh on this book you give me a book
report because i i already told you she
said i got a book for you i said i tell
you right now i don't read hey i i think
the guy's story is a worthy story to
tell but you know what so
as much as those are but the thing is
this country doesn't even [ __ ] about our
story are you ready for this
he contacted me the other day a couple
of days ago and he says hey
my wife said to go ahead and give you a
call i don't know if you're even
interested if you'd even consider this
yes it is
he's done i think he's only four
independent films you know he does it
himself he's got the equipment he does
his own don't go over there man i'm over
here and he says
we're doing an independent film
and we've got a character
i don't know if you want to play a
i think i got to do it leader of a
cartel a mexican drug cartel
said oh if he would have said you
well okay also let me say this
i don't know david rocha
but also
you don't come from this story
and then end up writing a movie where
you where a guy's a [ __ ] drug cartel
guy i'm gonna tell you that right now
because that doesn't do us any good
doesn't do us as a culture any good you
know it's not going to be it's not the
godfather about saved by a long stretch
right
you agree not that guy's not going to
write the guy
you're perpetuating what people think of
us already there you go all right how
about this one
when i was a little kid i watched i love
lucy every day black and white nine
years old seven years old eight-year-old
then i started watching chico in the man
73-77 i graduated 79 i started doing
comedy in 79.
42 years later there's only one person
in the history of television who has a
show named after him about him that's
latino
i love lucy was not about
desi arnaz chico and the man
was not about
the third one george lopez not the
george lopez show george lopez
two years down
that's badass so i'm opening a nursing
home
i'm only hiring you guys that are like
like
when the when the first little cuardo
started to come out probably about 16.
give me a job there yeah you passed your
palace
no i should open it if i want to open a
place that was a [ __ ] social place i
took care of old people
i jacked them off in the morning at
night to have them sleep
how old would i have to be the nurses be
at least 18. let's start looking let's
start hiring right now
gail
818 533 1843
what questions do you want
here's the question we want to ask see
if you agree
do we do we have to become a a product
of our environment
i say
no
you're not no but some of your friends
did some of your friends became right so
my friends became sure yeah
no i'm
do what you want to do you don't have to
be a product of your environment so
let's say this so there was a guy that
that played sports with us when he when
he got out of
uh junior high he started sniffing glue
and all this stuff like
how does that guy go that way so
whoever's listening you want a number
again
because i think these are these are
really good questions like
what guy was your best what guy or girl
was your friend growing up
that you live close together but your
lives took such a drastic turn well i i
i can say that yeah i had several
friends that were like that that we
grew up close together on the block were
good friends
and
then they went one way and some of us
went the other and all of that was
at that time because the vietnam era was
going on those guys that went into the
service
ended up leaving
living
productive lives
those that didn't just like the cop that
took me home
those that didn't remain either dead or
in prison today we're not talking about
but 1789. if you have that call up
four three 818-5333-1843 not even that
yeah it could be that it could be you
know people like you know the thing you
said like when vietnam happened like
eight guys on your street passed yeah
like that you know somebody that was
with you
some girl that was your best friend that
you think were never going to be
separated and then you're separated then
you know
are they a product or environment did
they have a chance to that somebody
reached out to them and helped them
sure there's always and good people
there there's a man on the 15th of
october i'm going to a funeral a
gentleman by the name of larry camacho
larry camacho and his son was one year
older than i was but larry on the block
tried to get the guys to work out tried
to he was a good guy
tried to do everything did so much he
was a good guy finally just old age
natural cause he passed away
and his services are going to be on the
15th what did he do
he i don't know what he did for regular
living you know he's a hard working man
he had a nice house his wife
uh two daughters and the son
three daughters and a son
and he just did everything to try to
keep the boys
out of trouble
he's a good guy he was a positive
influence
very positive here's another question
what's the number again 818 533 1840.
okay
when i was growing up
i was afraid of everything but then some
of the guys i went to school with
[ __ ] ninth grade they weren't afraid
of [ __ ]
how does somebody who's 15 years old not
afraid of the police man like where they
come from
like when they're 15 they don't give a
[ __ ] about the police they're 20 they
don't give a [ __ ] about the police 25
30.
so are if you're 15 and you're hard like
that like like you don't care about
going to the principal's office you
don't care about getting suspended and
then you graduate or maybe you don't
graduate from high school do you stay do
you stay
like a [ __ ] hard ass your whole life
or can somebody get to you
and turn your life around in the 20s or
30s or 40s unless there's something
major yeah unless there's something
major to impact your life
uh you're setting that's your formative
years
where you're setting who you are and
what you what you believe in and i have
to say that a lot of that has to come
from the home how you were treated in
the home which you lived with which
already you're losing because already
you know and so once you get that far
where you're not afraid of anybody or
anything
well then you're behind the times and
you're going to end up
there's a greater chance that you're
going to end up with problems let's say
this so you're wherever i don't want to
say ellie you're wherever you are
wherever you live with this podcast is
you're 25 in your heart you didn't
graduate from high school maybe you went
to a vocational place you didn't go so
you end up going and becoming a busboy
or dishwasher middle night whatever
and
you're probably gonna you're probably
gonna meet a girl that's you know
either from that place or a friend of
your friends from a diner and stuff like
that right so now you know am i right or
am i is that what i think you're gonna
meet people around your level right sure
so so that dude's a little bit mean
you know he came up the way is maybe as
a girlfriend he's mean to his girlfriend
can that [ __ ] guy turn it around or
is he just gonna be a part of his
environment for his whole life no if he
if he can turn around but there's
you know you you can
you can move out of the barrio but there
are times where you can't take the body
out of the boy
so if everything continues to go with
that new girlfriend you know that's
impacting him and change of life as long
as he doesn't go back to his environment
it's going to be fine but once he gets
back around and he starts really there's
problems over here with with the old
lady and he goes back to his
old living his dad his mom the
influences that impacted him during his
informative years
then it's going to be uh
i mean it's formerly because you know
what i think this i think i think that
i think that a guy like that can maybe
go to go eat at a diner maybe the girl's
a
waitress he's a hard dude he sees her
they talk he's not but he's got a heart
he's got a soul inside that he starts to
soften up
goes to a place and maybe starts to
soften up if he gets away he can't even
still be in an environment but if you're
around guys that
are only gonna you know like [ __ ] that
guy over there or [ __ ] him let's go over
here but i think that guy needs to be
separate a little bit and start to
really look at people and appreciate
people i don't think that guy
is impossible to turn around i just
think i just think if he hangs around
with guys that are like him even if he's
good they'll keep they'll keep him like
that i remember and i won't mention any
names but there was a there was a guy
that we helped put together he went to
jail for murder you know he put him in
jail for murder this one i was still
working uh patrol in east l.a
and i knew the whole family
and so now years later now i'm married i
have kids
my youngest
is playing t-ball
and i run into one of the brothers
and he comes up and says hey creole and
i say what's going on
he says hey man i just want you to know
i'm changed i'm different i moved out of
the barrio all i'm trying to do is raise
my family over here it looks like our
boys i said hey
it's okay
you know just do good
that same little boy that played t-ball
with my son
ended up years later coaching my
grandson
in
baseball so that that the guy the dad
did good i said how about your brother
he's well my brother's still in the
joint and his brother ended up passing
away in the joint but this guy stood
clean moved out with the family hey
nothing i said hey
that was then this is now god bless you
i hope everything goes good and it did
his son
ended up coaching my grandson in
baseball so you can turn your life
around yeah
it's possible so people that are
listening
you don't have to especially now you
know everybody's trying to live a life
on instagram they don't live just in
your heart man know that you don't have
to become a product of your environment
exactly or that you don't have to
pretend you're bigger than you are
or that you don't have to pretend you
have more money or a better car or
whatever people look at that think that
make you a better person none of that
[ __ ] makes you a [ __ ] better person
not the size of your house not your
[ __ ] car not your watch
you don't have to look at each other and
still find the connection amongst like
the chemistry of each other sure
certainly
absolutely i don't know what's in that
[ __ ] is that deep chopra's [ __ ]
weed
all right are we done because that's
straight from the dialogue yeah um uh
we've done our voicemails we can oh
we'll do some
okay
what happened to our little girl either
though
i haven't checked on her i'll check on
her over the week i'll see if i can oh
yeah nothing let's uh throw on those
headphones gentlemen so we can
wait let me see
and thanks for getting our [ __ ] pizza
over here have a [ __ ] beautiful show
at the anniversary show here it was last
time
hello anniversary show gil these are all
questions for you eh never give a [ __ ]
the people do like to ask you a question
i better not go
wait where's mine oh
if i go to a spare rhino
we should get one of the girls from
experimental come in here
talk about tips and there you go talk
about tips
why the name is always act me on the
receipt
yeah first one
what up boy got two questions one for
george did you ever run into norm
mcdonald while uh you were on the road
did you ever have any crazy stories i'm
sure you did and also did you ever meet
a guy named tim wilson like a country
comedian he passed away in 2014 just
wondering if you ever knew him oh and a
question for gail
do you guys in on the force or anything
ever have any like conspiracies that the
general public don't believe but all the
officers and whatnot they're like oh
yeah you already know
like
jfk was killed or some [ __ ] like that is
there a computer so you guys are in the
know on and it's like a circle thing
where you guys know what happened but
you don't know what happened or
also is there a conspiracy that you're
interested in and you like really follow
uh just let me know gil thanks
hey all right so that's a two [ __ ] part
question oh [ __ ] that dude you had two
for me george hi do you start your
gate with a right foot or left foot
uh
answer his questions first no
disappointment i hate to disappoint you
no conspiracies that uh i'm aware of but
there's a lot of conspiracies out there
certainly no conspiracies that the
my colleagues talk about uh we're just
when it comes to conspiracies we're just
like you we follow them in the public
eye we don't really know about them
well i'm gonna say it's a little bit
different because i'm gonna say it's
different because right now on the
floors there has to be comps that think
a certain way and there's because think
a certain other way and i don't think
it's you one-on-one one-on-one i think
it's groups of guys like in prison you
have guys that group that believe one
thing
guys believe about the thing got the
other thing i think it's that same thing
with uh police if you look at an office
a police uh like they got a call and
they said hey we're not we're none of
all of us quit
so you have a unity in the police
department that you probably didn't have
when you were a police officer but that
is almost reminiscent of what uh how
people in prisons kind of set up
well
in in my world
26 years of working murders i worked on
evidence i didn't work on theories so
it's either there so that's right if you
don't have facts and conspiracies are
normally
not factual you know they have theories
and that's what they that's why they
call them conspiracy theories so if
there's not facts or something some kind
of evidence to back them up we don't pay
attention because there's enough
problems especially when i was working
there's enough problems working our
murders without worrying about somebody
else so you're not one of those fools in
arizona that's already counted the
elections three times and every time
they come
biden wins by more and they still think
it's a [ __ ] conspiracy yeah i don't
follow conspiracy okay good
what was the question for me uh great so
that's norma mcdonald listen
yeah nor mcdonald was a great guy he was
a funny dude man he was very dry bruce
alford who did my show did an arm show
and norm was great i got nothing well i
can't even say i have nothing bad to say
about normal i love norm norm was a
comedian uh comedians comedian he had a
great audience and he uh
wasn't afraid to uh gamble which i love
no one was a no one was a gambler man he
knew he was in your sports and uh he'll
he'll be missed yeah that's great
um and then was uh tim wilson are you
familiar with yeah you know i knew a guy
tim wilson you know the crazy thing is
you know because we're talking about
[ __ ] 79 80 90s jim also was a good
dude man and i remember him i remember
running him clubs and stuff like that
and uh
uh yeah thank you for letting me know um
i'm sorry that he passed but uh tim
wilson was a fun dude
that's great yeah
i mean we're time off from the 70s to i
mean imagine man i'm looking
you know what i wanted to ask you did
you ever run into stevens
you know the only reason i'm mad at
steven because i will [ __ ] hire me
[ __ ] general i'm seeking
all right uh number two in the
relationship another one
ah oh my god hi what's up george the
simon from seattle uh just calling in
man i've been in a relationship for like
[ __ ] 15 years already
three kids with her and you know
i'm a dog i've been cheating here and
there she knows this uh
that's one to know man then
do i just keep [ __ ] wrestling [ __ ]
out for my kids or
what the [ __ ] do i do man i feel like
i'm happiest at the house when i'm with
my boys
and my daughters but [ __ ] i look at
her and i'm like gosh i just want to
find a dime
let me know what's up man see that's
what i'm saying
you know these dudes man like
it i can't need help
no i think you got it hey man if you
took the if you took the pill you got to
stay in there with it right if you say
that's my old lady that's your old lady
that's your lady yeah
it really hits when he's like yeah and
she knows about it too
yeah
next thing you just say is they have
invited my two boys for a threesome yeah
but you don't respect that thing is that
thing right yeah how's the guy well so
that's a guy right there that has been
with somebody for a while and still
trying to be like
a young a young person
you know what i got my man alex cantor
can you can you can we get him on here
over the thing uh
yeah aaron can we get him on the phone
somehow
uh yeah do you want us to call in
uh here let me give you the number
because my phone's almost dead because
we were in denver and i wanted to tell
you how the tacos were received in
denver because he came here when we were
just starting aquabus
wagon
so that way he can tell you like it's a
it's taking off man
and he was in here when it was it was
brand new
and then anna navarro called because i
wanted her to give us an update on her
coronavirus
who got
is she the one was she one of the ones
that got off oh she was my wife was
asking i said i don't know i saw two of
them but i think she got a false
negative off of that girl's thing that
girl's test
there was questions about that i had
questions about that why because she had
tested yeah but two of them tested
they'll be throwing my [ __ ] porn on
there
is that my no two of them it tested
positive but the other two were just as
you know they were close why didn't they
just shut it down all together why
didn't all four of them go good because
that's because they went live
yeah that
didn't seem uh
oh that's cool is that alex cantor
yeah
i'm just trying to keep it off the
screen
no don't worry about it man i don't want
to block it out here
that's really hard
all right
this is alexa
alex yeah yeah yeah
hello hey man
hey
what's up i'm right here with gail on
the podcast hello alex
oh what's up how's it going guys we
wanted you to give a update on
everything that what happened at uh at
the paramount theater when when you're
uh when when you went out there
yeah yeah happy to happen to share that
so we had uh we had quite a quite a
turnout this weekend which was a
doordash right
next door dog which one
what's that what remind me of the
company
uh this is uh this is next fight
uh the food truck that we brought up to
uh up to the
your performance in denver on friday
right
yes so next fight went out there like
they were said like they set it up they
said hey a couple weeks ago alex you
know they're in colorado the next
fight's over they're going to come when
i'm at the paramount theater and they're
going to come and set up hey listen i've
seen a lot of those go south but this
one wasn't that huh
uh
so we you know we we've been planning
this in conjunction with your with your
live show because we thought it was
going to be a great way to spread
awareness of the brand
and uh we we had the taco truck come
load up at 4 p.m right out from the
theater in downtown denver
and served i think over 3 000 tacos in a
couple hours for all the people coming
to the show and just people in general
in the denver neighborhood and we gave
out all these free tacos as a big
promotional
um
you know activation pop-up that we did
we wrapped a truck with your face on it
and uh and everyone got to got to try
their uh their george lopez tacos and it
was a huge success we had
a line around the corner at one point i
think there were over 500 people in line
after the show got out but we served
them all uh tacos they all got to try it
out and then we had it come around
uh to the back to feed the the staff in
the venue after the show was over too so
thank you for
helping arrange that yeah he fed
everybody from the crew so so in uh in
uh in your business are we the number
one uh brand so far like from you better
believe it yeah well you're the top
selling taco on on the platform you guys
you guys are crushing it i think you're
in uh 30 something states across the
country now wow we've got
mama you're helping mom and pop
businesses everywhere to sell more food
out of their restaurant and we should
feel really proud about that yeah you
know what that's a great thing alex you
know the uh
there was there was a far there was a
drug store over there by where i used to
get my mail a hardware store i mean and
the guy went out of business because you
know larger places open so yeah to be
able to help a
mom and pop business is
awesome yeah yeah it was a it's a really
great uh thing that you're doing and and
you know you've got a great audience
that loves you
and when they see that you're doing
something they want to try it and and
it's really
you know it's really helping these
restaurants do more orders every day out
of their existing kitchens and um
allowing them to to reach more customers
outside of their four walls through all
these delivery apps like doordash and
postmates ubereats
so that that's what that's where all
these people are are ordering it from
and uh and it's it's yeah it's a really
great uh great partnership so thank you
let me ask a question do you ever see
the food truck going to the raider game
we should we should absolutely bring the
food truck to the raider game we should
uh we should go tailgate and hand out uh
lots of talkers to everyone who's coming
for the uh
for the for the football game you know i
think that's a great idea you know what
i think we should do i think we should
go underneath the stadium
and as the game is over and as the
visitors bus is there and as the raiders
come out of their uh dressing room go
into their car we have the food truck
there and we feed the we feed the
players that just played the game
i love that but let's uh let's let's
sync up and see if we can uh we can
arrange that you know the the great
thing about a food truck is it's mobile
and we could uh we can drive it anywhere
so and and pop up and and hand out tacos
as long as uh
you know as long as uh we have places to
park it and all the right tournaments
and everything which is something that
our team will handle yeah yeah all right
good man i just wanted to say
all right alex
thank you so much for for the call and
great job on friday it was an amazing
performance and uh it was great uh great
to have all all the people from our team
come down and and check it out and see
you perform so thank you thank you all
right that was great see you later thank
you alex
yeah thank you bye
awesome well
yeah for hey let's keep let's keep it
rolling got uh
another voicemail
dionda george was so guilty
so uh
mad respect for guild man i'm a
mta formerly known as rtd bus driver now
man but
i got a little pickle set up with your
ass man
it is not
bro
if you want to do the proper translation
hey uh quick question uh
that episode
of your show when you had cheats in
chiang mai i think it was both of them
you guys were crazy lit that day right
all right man you enjoy the show what's
on there uh i did the uh
it sort of keeps going but what happened
when you did the uh
chichen chang episode were you guys as
as lit as the caller
which one which one what episode uh
would you do an episode of your imagine
your sitcom or maybe the the talk show
okay
yeah we're all [ __ ] up
and there you go
so the answer is
hey but i don't know this dude right
here is super
super chill
this guy gave me his number this stuff's
pretty good man yeah oh that was guilt
that's great i want you to take one of
these
and go in the opposite direction
[Laughter]
all right is there another one that's
great we got more so many uh pestos out
there i mean i mean women
hey jorge george george lopez
a big fan man from fresno california a
lot of pisces out there a lot of
basically and
you know how the mexican americans love
to see the basic leaves out there
actually realistically anyways uh my dad
is a golfer as well
and he has one question to ask he said
how much is it to play at the
pebble beach
so basically that's all he wants to know
it's a lot of money so
uh all the way from des moines iowa i
moved out here because it's cheaper
but uh it's cheaper
oh i forgot to tell you my name my
name's hector excellent
so uh yeah
you know what i think uh pebble beach is
can you look at him but i'm pretty sure
that you know before you used to be able
to go over there and play
and then it got you know it was it was
always specific like 400 500 but i think
it's like almost a grand day and i think
you have to stay in the hotel for like
three days so
it probably costs five thousand dollars
to play
so yes but but
not i'm not saying it's not worth it
uh from 2019 this is an article um
standard round is 550 per person oh and
it increased this is why there's an
article it increased to 575 per person
april 1st of last year
oh and then in addition it's 45 dollars
to use a cart
and a caddy fee is 95 per bag
yeah
that's why i stay off the golf course
it's expensive but you know uh
yeah i don't know i think golf
i would have never thought that i would
become a golfer fun
it's a good it's a good thing i think i
think golf could take a dude that was
like a hardened dude and
and you know when you give somebody
something a challenge other than what
they're used to doing like you said like
you said before idle hands
either shooting a basketball or playing
golf or stuff like that like there would
be some churros over there now carrico
that you would see them and they'd like
shave heads and they had their clubs and
they could [ __ ] hit it man
you know michael jordan said after he
retired from basketball playing golf is
like the thing that kept him going he
needed to get his competitive energies
out somewhere
yeah
i think uh
charles barked the worst thing
still got the big gamblers man
because you know they get their
adrenaline from somewhere yeah
is there another one one more let's find
something
just that girl the lady that well i
never contacted her back i'll see if i
can find her and
get her back uh see what's going on in
her life there we go hey we're pearl
good man we have some questions hi this
is gene from orange county i have a
question for both george and gil
gil you and your partner worked really
hard on the night soccer case what did
you do to celebrate once that case was
done did you go on vacation anywhere
with your family or did you just go back
to work the next day
and george without giving away any
celebrity names can you tell us any
behind the scenes secrets of celebrities
that were high maintenance or drama when
you had your duck show
that's a great
you're [ __ ] hey right well but you go
first those are very very good and
sincere questions
right after the conviction of richard
ramirez
my wife and family we took off to hawaii
and spent a week in hawaii and that was
that was a release for all of us we
needed to get away we needed to have
some fun and do something to just
get back to earth let me ask questions
so every day that you
but that that was your focal point right
like catching rich remix yes okay so
every day when you got up
uh how did you feel going into work
you had there had to be some like uh
pant little not panicked but like
apprehension nervousness every day every
day getting up and ready to go to work
is what do we need to do today what did
i learn last night what notes do i have
to follow up on it was all about work
what what did you expect what happened
on the
because you know they did the thing
where he laughed and he came back did
you think that somebody would encounter
him in the house and maybe like like uh
you know what i mean he he'd have to
fight somebody or take off ryan we
thought he would come back we thought he
would come back to the dental office he
had somebody in there and then the
executive on our department made him
made us pull the guys out because they
were making overtime they weren't doing
anything and then the day we pulled him
out bigger than [ __ ] he went in there
the next day so we anticipated him going
back there
we didn't anticipate him going anywhere
we were just following up leads and
doing what we had to do do you think
right now in los angeles there's cases
where there's a uh
a pattern of a person out there right
now
uh that maybe the the news isn't
treating like a serial killer
i don't know you know there are there
are serial killers out there and you
know they've never been caught right
yeah that have never been caught you
don't know there's a serial killer until
they have
a few in a row and you know you don't
know
there's a lot that goes into it you you
should be treating
every murder you get
like the first one in a series
so you'd be able to pick it up no matter
what you do okay i'm not a professional
i'm not a police officer but you want me
to tell you why
there's not a lot of latino serial
killers i would i would hope you tell me
anything because eventually they're
going to need a ride
all right that's it
you